hey guys welcome back to brandy we're
back I'm forming it in today's Thursday
it's deaf sheer recap day or know what's
going on and today there really isn't
much news today a few bits of
information that we're told about and
some new mask outfits as well coming so
very interesting news like I said but
there wasn't a lot it's why gonna be
like that for the next couple weeks
which sucks but hopefully we'll get some
more information on the marching fire
heroes that being Cheon Dee and Xiao Lin
or maybe we'll get the other two as well
with that like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe for new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the event to quests and all that
other type stuff like that with that
let's get started so first up the warden
and the Valkyrie work leaks that we
talked about and a couple days ago are
confirmed to be true but they will be
coming in season seven which is really
nice as well a lot of people have been
wanting warden in duck to get their
rework the rigs are confirmed but the
changes in those works are going to be a
little bit different there are some
things in those leaks that weren't
supposed to be shown or weren't showing
that are going to be in the reworks in
the future so there are still tons of
other changes that we don't know about
so click the I in the top right if you
haven't seen that video and you want to
see what some of those changes are and
is well you can also click the I on the
top right again and you'll be taken to
the patch 1.25 video since that was also
released today that being Thursday the
patch came with changes such as the
revenge health and bug fixes and other
things like that so as we click the I on
the top right to be taken to both of
those videos if you haven't seen those
and as well a quick reminder that the
for honor on Steam and do play is gonna
be 75% off until July 5th do you have
about one more week until that goes away
that's gonna be 75% for all the
additions including standard and the
gold edition and then as well on July
5th is the release of our tech test for
PC sadly this is an NDA so if you don't
know what that means basically even if I
do happen to get the said tech test I
will not be allowed to stream it game
play or post any photos on the community
to have or anything like that or it
could be really bad news for me some
legal issues the test will include the
breach mode and the new character
shelving and chianti for us to test out
and show the bug fixes for so good luck
to all those who get it because many
people will probably not get those the
new content of the week is gonna be mask
outfits so there's gonna be costing
20,000 Steve we've never had mask
outfits outside of an event before so
this is something entirely new the
Knights are gonna get one called Oh
genius the Vikings are getting something
called nidhogg and the samurai are gonna
get Korra Madoka I'm pretty sure I
butchered all three of those names but
I'll play the video in the background as
we talk about these the outfits and the
masks looked pretty damn cool and yes
there are now 10
giggles and for honor so if you're into
that there you go and how coincidental
that the samurai happen to get these
tentacles as well but yeah other than
that they showed some of the fanfic any
fan art from the community corner and
all that good stuff so that really
wasn't in terms of actual info but other
than that that's good we end of the
video if the video of the content of the
week isn't done by the time I'm done
talking then that'll just be the end
since this was a really short video I
want to leave you guys offer the
question what's gonna be your most
favorite thing about the marching fire
update or what your most hyped about
that could be the new characters some of
the know the two characters that we've
seen game before Shaolin and Cheon Dee
or the two characters Jang's Union nukes
you who we haven't seen yet or the
breech fire mode or anything like that
but regardless like the V if you do
enjoy for this really quick video
hopefully we get some decent information
next week about anything that's coming
toward the game subscribe for new like I
said I covered the informational site a
foreigner that being balance changes
information patch notes all that good
stuff my two most recent videos would be
on the screen if you guys want to check
that out and that guy's so every great
yesterday maybe Forks in the video and
peace out